hey this is called the trick with reason
TV we're here at the republican national
convention it's 2016 we're trying to
figure out what this is we're trying to
figure out where this convention stands
in history and what's the future for the
Republican Party as of right now it's
pretty weird no not because of the
abundance of American flag clothing or
Donald Trump memorabilia because no
matter where you walk around the 2016
for public and National Convention you
can't shake the feeling that everyone is
holding on to an era that once was
marriage can only be between a man and a
woman well I believe abortion is wrong
no we do not want to be liberal we are
conservative people and we stand for In
God We Trust in fact the grand old
party's claim that it was the party of
fiscal responsibility limited government
and personal freedom was exposed as a
lie a long time ago ladies and gentlemen
welcome to trump land he's interested in
making America great again he what does
I mean what does it mean it means that
we need to be the greatest country in
the world and we are not the greatest
country in the world I don't think it
was the prototype come on now get real
who else what a who else would make
America great but Donald Trump it's
gonna make our military stronger and
he's gonna build a wall and Mexico's
gonna pay for it no no Mexico's not
gonna pay or are you wait and see but
despite the rhetoric this theatrical
ceremony of stars and stripes could turn
out to be awake for the party of Lincoln
what are you doing here how do you feel
about the future of the GOP well I think
I feel good about the future
we're going to have a new new president
it's going to tell it like it is and do
what needs to be done why are you
supporting Donald Trump he says
everything I want to say that I can't
say but he can not every delegate at
this year's convention is firmly in the
Trump camp on day one the nevertrump
movement tried one last procedure will
move to stop the latest mistake on the
lake but to no avail
what about a third party candidate I
think a lot of people might hear might
support Gary Johnson I think you're
probably right he's kind of like the
grown up in the room right I'm
supporting mr. Trump because he's the
child in the room he's I didn't say it
was the child but he's you know we have
to be had such a contentious primary
than I think that's kind of what i mean
by hit by Johnson being kind of the
adult in the room I voted for for Gary
Johnson in 2012 with Hillary Clinton or
Donald Trump the question is you want to
get a knockout blow to your head or do
you want to knockout blow to your heart
and I'm going to vote for for Donald
Trump you know I mean so you know I
you're playing into the two-party
paradigm no but exactly i mean i'm
playing into the two-party paradigm but
I recognize that both parties were
basically going to have somebody that
was extreme if you're not sitting at the
table you're going to be served up for
dinner will trump make America great
again yeah maybe he will
you